dass ein außenminister einen nato
treffen früher verlassen muss kommt
schon mal vor dass es gestern in berlin
ausgerechnet der türkische ist wirft
fragen auf etwa blockiert das land die
nord erweiterung der nato und das würden
sie auch gerne in finnland wissen wo die
finnische regierung das land in die nato
führen will und wo der finnische
präsident von seinem letzten telefonat
mit seinem türkischen kollegen erdogan
berichtet kitu cup himself wie vor bei
hat das thema selbst aufgegriffen und
nie gesagt sie bewerben sich doch für
die nato und wir werden das positiv
bewerten
daher verstehen sie sicher dass ich
jetzt etwas verwirrt bild computer womit
er nicht der einzige wäre zurück in
berlin wo fast alle die perspektive bald
neue nordeuropäer dabei zu haben so
positiv sehen wie die deutsche
außenministerin
schweden und finnland sind nicht nur
unsere partner nicht nur unsere freunde
sondern sie sind bereits langen unserer
europäischen familienmitglieder zur nato
familie wollen sie jetzt auch in
schweden gehören gestern abend sprechen
sich die regierenden sozialdemokraten
für den beitritt aus was sie dafür
brauchen die zustimmung aller 30
aktuellen nato staaten und in berlin so
berichten mehrere diplomaten wird die
außenministerin aus dem noch nicht nato
land schweben vom außenminister aus dem
nato land türkei heftig angegangen nach
seinem applaus stellt der oberste
türkische diplomat dann bedingungen etwa
ein härteres vorgehen gegen die
kurdische pkk oder
rüstungslieferungen an die türkei
das ist auch keine verhandlungsmasse das
ist eine voraussetzung für ein bündnis
das klingt wenig versöhnlich und umso
überraschender wirkt die zuversicht des
nato generalsekretärs
die türkei hat klargestellt dass eine
blockade nicht ihre absicht ist
29 nato partner sind sich einig in
berlin es soll jetzt schnell gehen mit
der nord erweiterung
das soll bitte nichts dazwischen kommen
auch nicht der dreißigste partner
und gunnar krueger hat für uns das nato
außenministertreffen beobachtet erstmals
schönen guten morgen
wird ankara und ich glaube die frage
stellen sich gerade alle den beitritt
schwedens und finnlands blockieren
beziehungsweise verzögern um etwas für
sich rauszuholen
die türkei musste für so eine blockade
wirklich einen sehr hohen politischen
preis bezahlen so wie sie ja auch einen
ihrerseits einen preis ein fordert eben
ein entgegenkommen bei den themen kurden
und waffen es ist manchmal wie auf einem
basar sagt der dienstälteste der
außenminister gestern und das ist der
luxemburger jean asselborn da muss man
verhandeln aber am ende wird es dann
schon gehen es ist zugleich auch ein
bisschen ein treppenwitz der jüngeren
nato geschichte dass dieser basar nun in
berlin beginnt denn man hat sich hier in
form er getroffen das heißt also ohne
diplomaten man hat relativ ungezwungen
miteinander geredet und das ist
eigentlich die antwort von berlin
gewesen auf diese französische diagnose
die nato sei hirntot nun ist diese
diagnose wahrscheinlich überholt nach
dem angriffskrieg von putin auf die
ukraine aber die notwendigkeit für
solche informellen treffen das zeigt
diese dieser widerstand der türken diese
notwendigkeit die ist größer denn je und
hat gerade die ukraine angesprochen und
den angriffskrieg in brüssel wird ja
auch immer noch über das geplante
öl-embargo gegen russland diskutiert wie
weit ist denn die eu da gekommen
nicht wirklich weiter und die
außenminister werden heute
wahrscheinlich auch nicht wirklich
weiter kommen es sind ja die
eu-botschafter die sich über dieses
thema zu beugen haben und das machen sie
nun schon mehr als eine woche länger als
ursprünglich geplant und darüber wächst
eben auch der ärger im kreis der
außenminister der ärger richtet sich
aber nicht nur gegen ungarn sondern vor
allem auch gegen die eu kommission das
ein schlechtes handwerk gewesen ist
sozusagen der tenor die kommission habe
diesen vorschlag nicht gut abgestimmt
bevor sie ihn unterbreitet hat sie habe
zu sehr darauf vertraut dass die dinge
schon auf ihren fallen werden und
zweitens habe man danach nicht wirklich
gutes krisenmanagement betrieben ursula
von der leyen ist ja letzte woche nach
budapest gereist aber sie ist eben nur
dorthin gereist und nicht in die anderen
hauptstädte die dieses öl embargo
kritisch sehen so habe man orban wieder
zum klassensprecher gemacht so seien
auch die bemühungen der letzten zwei
drei monate einigkeit zu zeigen ein
bisschen ins risiko geraten man ist
eigentlich stolz darauf diese einigkeit
aber beim öl hört diese einigkeit
offenbar auf dass es für alle sichtbar
und eben auch für putin und für manche
auch verständlich gunnar krüger mit den
einschätzungen unseres korrespondent
entschuldigung live aus brüssel vielen
dank